everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're gonna be going
over at the conquest attack it's a
variation in the Evans gambit declined
line trying to give white more options
to continue an attack when black does
not want to come along for the ride in
the accepted lines in the Emmons game if
you're not familiar with the evans game
it one of the more popular game that
you'll see out there efore e5 Knight f3
knight c6 and then after Bishop come to
the center of the board white decides I
want to give up some material so plays
b4 now the accepted line is the Bishop
takes here c3 Bishop comes back to a5
since it's under attack and then pawn d4
now this pawn is being pinned down to
the king
so does have to think about that but why
it's gonna go down material here but
really opening up a lot of the lines for
his pieces to get really involved into
the game you could see while White's
focused on the center Black has been
moving his Bishop around here quite a
few moves has not really developed any
of his other material so yes White's
gonna go down a little bit but does have
a lot of attacking lines in the decline
line in the Evans gambit black says yeah
I don't even want to take that material
here on b4 I'm gonna come back to b6
keep my pressure here on at the f2 pawn
which at the beginning is only defended
by the King on a one I'm not playing
your games now the mainline continues
why it's gonna push forward a4 just
starting to put pressure onto this
Bishop here if black does not respond
with something like a six then just
pushing forward to a5 it's gonna be
extremely good for whites but usually we
are gonna see this a six and then the
pond could push forward if he wants here
to a4 but more common is Knight to c3
just getting more material involved into
the center of the game and then Knight
to f6 black does have a few options here
but Knight to f6 is extremely common and
this is where we get into the conquest
attack because by default there's a lot
of options this is the decline line so
no materials come off the board here
pretty safe to play castle on the King
side could bring your knight up here
- d5 a nice little outpost here if he
wants to exchange with his knight that's
gonna be completely okay or if you just
want to push forward a 5 the ship comes
back here to a7 that's fine as well
really starting to squeeze here on the
queenside limit the squares that your
opponent can go to but the conquest
attack says I'm not okay with any of
those I'm still comfortable giving up
some material because I want a strong
attack I want to really open up this
board state and really attack my
opponent and so that's where we come up
with a conquest attack of D for now our
opponents never have to do exactly want
that what we want them to so they don't
have to take this material here they
could castle on the King side if they do
or if they play another move like d6
both of those cases are gonna end up
with us taking here on e5 and this is
probably not best for black but
sometimes if they're in that Evans game
a decline line they're just like I'm not
taking a gambit doesn't even matter they
could bring their knight down to g4
we're gonna castle on the King side they
may take this material back we could see
an exchange right here and then after
the night comes attacks our Bishop push
you back to b3 this is gonna be
completely fine neither side is up
material right here but I do think White
has a very strong game in this spot so
if we come back and say what if doesn't
castle on the King side what if they
instead decide to play d6 gonna be the
same thing but it's gonna be slightly
variation depending on how they exchange
material Knights usually going to take
we could see take right here pawn takes
and then you can see yes the Queen's
come off the board some people don't
like to play when the Queen's come off
the board that early but that just is
how it's going to work out but now when
the King takes the bishop can freely
take here on f7 so this does give some
options for whites to get some material
here if we see the bishop debt down to
d4 this is a great outpost move pretty
easy just play rook to a3 defending this
Knights are gonna be castling on the
Kings side pretty soon here because they
could be playing
Knight g4 starting to put a lot of
pressure on the F to square so that's
what's gonna happen if they don't take
the material more than likely from what
I've seen they are going to take that
material in the center of the board so
we're gonna look at the main variations
if they decide to take that material
after you play d4 let's say they decide
to take with their pawn right here which
makes a lot of sense they're giving up
their central a pawn but it does take a
material also attacks the night here on
c3 and white has a couple options but I
would recommend the knight coming to d5
this gives you a lot of variations where
black can make some mistakes usually
they're going to take with their knight
right here they don't have to if they
decide you I'm just not taking that
material that castle on the King side
Bishop to g5 pinning down the knight to
the Queen this is a combo that you'll
see quite a bit in this conquest attack
but this is both attacking with the
knight right here and of the bishop same
thing is instead of if they cast on the
King side they could play d6 here same
thing Bishop to d6 yeah they want to get
their Bishop involved into the game but
this is putting a lot of pressure on
this knight on f6 we've already squeezed
their Queen side over here this is
adding pressure on the King side but
more than likely they're going to take
with their knight Knight takes pawn is
gonna capture here and then they have a
couple options the main line is going to
be to play Queen to e7 attacking our
side and although it looks weird the
best move for white is to play King to
f1 we really like our Queen here on d1
it's eventually going to defend this
pawn here on d4 if the knight gets
involved into the game don't want to
bring it over here and just exchange off
the board right away why it is down
material here and so wants to keep that
Queen to make it just easier to get back
later on to the game now from here if
they play e5
which is pretty common their knights
under attack they no longer have a check
that they're putting on White's now a
very good move would be to play d6 and
the reason for this is if they are going
to take
with their queen then Bishop to f4 puts
a lotta pressure onto them the Knights
being pinned down yes the Knights also
attacking it as well
and this is gonna be a very good spots
for for black so just keep that in mind
if you see this position playing that d6
is going to be good now if we come back
if the Queen does not come to e7 they
may say hey my Knights under attack I'm
just gonna take this material here on b4
that's also fine just castle on the King
side yes you are going down some
material but later on you we will be
able to get this back pretty easily now
if we come back to this position in the
conquest attack instead upon taking
maybe the bishop takes here on d4 there
is going to be an exchange Knight takes
pawn takes here and the knight comes
back to d5 as we have seen before the
main difference is the bishop is not
here on b6 to defend the pawn on d4
usually the Knights going to exchange
right here we talked about what happens
if they do not here but the pawns gonna
recapture and usually the night comes
and takes down on before if it doesn't
great you don't have to worry about that
but now White's down to pawns and I'm
recommending here castle on the Kings
side this does put a lot of pressure if
black does not castle on the King side
for rook to e1 you have the bishop right
here which you could play pawn to d6 at
some point you can get the Queen
involved into the game the bishop can
start to attack very quickly so they
usually need to a castle on the King
side but as soon as they do
Bishop to a3 pinning down the Knights
right here we talked earlier about how
you get some of that material back I
said later on I don't want to do an
entire game to show because I want to
show different examples of variations
that you'll see in the conquest attack
but one example you could see a five
here defending this nights here on b4 so
an outpost move but then the bishop
takes pawn recaptures Queen to d4 and
it's gonna be very difficult to hold on
to this mess here or here on b4 you
can't just bring the pond down here
maybe they just said yeah okay don't
worry about it I'm gonna
get my bishop involved into the game
rook to be one you can see very easily
that why it's gonna be able to gobble up
this material and then all of a sudden
yeah we are even on board very open
board state as well and why it has very
active pieces this is one way that you
can get around or get some of that
material back that we talked about that
you've given up right away if we come
back instead of the bishop taking here
the last option would be for the knight
to take and this is also pretty common
and so the knight takes here on d4 it's
an outpost you're going to now take here
on e5 which is a little bit different in
the past we've been saying hey exchange
here on d4 and then they recapture and
the knight comes up here to d5 it's
gonna be slightly different in this case
I'm recommending the knight take here on
e5 now if they wants to castle on the
King side that's not the best move for
them but I would still go ahead and do
this in this case I would play pawn to
a5 the bishop comes back here and then
Bishop to e3 and if you're curious why
even that in-between move maybe you've
seen this in the past you're like yeah I
mean the bishop on a7 tends to be about
the same here the main reason for that
is if you see some exchanges going on
maybe they don't want to exchange in the
center because there's the bishop the
knight and the Queen right here you
could see the knight take here pawn
recaptures bishop takes and then when
the rook recaptures you can see how
black setup you usually want your rooks
on the back row connected usually we
want to bring them to the center of the
board to attack right now once you
recapture with your rook here on a7 this
is not the placement that you want with
the bishop here on b6 if there's an
exchange you can just recapture with
your pawn right here that's completely
fine you have double pawns on the C file
and then it goes to double bonds on the
beef out you're gonna be completely okay
you're just gonna push on the Queen side
of the board when you recapture with
your rook it's a slight slight
disadvantage for a bike you can always
overcome this but it is gonna take some
time usually gonna be bringing your rook
back here to a
and then swing it to the center of the
board so that's one of those small
little things where if you're curious
why you might play that Ponte a5 that is
exactly why
now instead of castling because castling
I don't think is the best option for for
black once we play that Knight to e5
another option would be Queen to e7
attacking the knight once you play this
Knight e5 which is this the one
variation that we are showing it here
you got a hold hold on to the fort here
so Bishop to f4 and then if they want to
take here on b4 cuz that is open here
you are getting you to bring your bishop
back here to d2 it is pinning down the
Knights here you just are gonna have to
defend then you're gonna be looking to
castle on the King side so that is the
conquest attack in the Evans gambit if
you ever play the image game definitely
one of my favorite openings I really
like giving out material early on for a
strong attack if you don't like giving
up some material feel like you can come
back later and with a strategic
advantage in controlling the center of
the board and the tempo get that
material back and have a strong
attacking game I do not recommend the
conquest attack because many times you
are giving up one or two pawns and you
will have to find a very aggressive line
to get that material back but if you can
this is a very strong attack to have in
the ambans game especially if you're
going up against these decline lines
which you will see quite often players
just don't like to play into the Evans
gambit so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video always looking to do
variations of opening sometimes they are
extremely unique like this sometimes
they are extremely common so if you have
an opening you say hey can you dig a
little bit deeper into this particular
very open variation feel free to let me
know the best way to get a hold of me is
email you could find the email on the
website about us or just the chess
websites at gmail.com thank you guys so
much for watching I'll see you guys in
the next video